hey everybody welcome welcome welcome
in to Market takes listen I know I know
you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and I
appreciate that hey I am Dion Rabon
reporter for the Wall Street Journal
this is Mark it takes today we are
breaking down the state of global
business the global economy we are
looking at manufacturing pmis those
purchasing managers indexes uh we're
gonna start talking about really the U.S
China Japan Russia uh we got reports on
the manufacturing sector from around the
globe s p Global puts out this report
once a month and February's reports
really interesting having some very
interesting things to say about the
state of the economy about the state of
business shipping manufacturing as you
know Manufacturing in U.S is a smaller
piece of the overall economy but
globally this still drives business so
we're going to be diving into what the
state of business is looking at these
purchasing managers indexes and talk
about what that could tell us for the
future uh not only for the US economy
but a global economy as you know there
have been some worries about a global
recession this year so of course we're
going to look through the headlines of
what these PMI reports tell us from
around the world we're going to talk
about what the biggest takeaways are
from today's reports of course we're
going to check in on the markets we're
going to start with commodities today
because those really are the biggest
beneficiaries or losers in some cases
from what we hear in these PMI reports
we're also going to talk about what this
tells us about the chances for a global
recession and what this tells us about
the state of global inflation inflation
around the world what's moving prices
how they're moving really these reports
they survey business owners from around
the globe they say hey how are things
going are they getting worse are they
getting worse are they getting better
what do you think and what are you
making of the business environment they
take those results and they put out a
report every month that tells us what
the state of global business is we are
going to be breaking all that down right
here on Market takes so without further
Ado uh the February PMI reports now SMP
FMP Global puts out a Global PMI
manufacturing report and that came in
right at 50. now 50 is important because
that's the line between contraction
anything below 50 shows that the sector
is Contracting getting smaller but
orders are decreasing business is
getting worse anything above 50 tells us
that we're expanding things are getting
better business is moving in a good
positive direction we hit right at 50
for the global manufacturing PMI report
and that's important because it shows
that we are returning to growth this
sector had been in contraction for the
previous few months and now we are
returning for the first time in seven
months to that positive 50 number and
we're seeing a bit of diversion a bit of
dispersion in terms of country reports
we're going to talk through that
output rules for the first time like I
said in seven months amid improving
Supply chains and China's reopening as
coveted restrictions were lifted
business optimism also revived that's
big rising to its highest level in a
year that is a big thing now the survey
number hitting 50 that can be a little
deceptive because when people think
about the globe they usually think U.S
Eurozone driven well the US and the
Eurozone were actually in contraction
the U.S manufacturer according to this
report from s p Global quote the
manufacturing sector remained in steep
decline in February a lack of new orders
suggests that production could
deteriorate further in the coming months
as factories deplete their pipelines of
previously placed orders now if you
watch Market takes you know that a big
part of U.S GDP over the past year or so
really and going back even a little bit
further than that has been the increase
in inventories companies buying a lot of
stuff that maybe they're not going to
sell today but they're just stockpiling
so that if the supply chains don't
deliver they don't run on a product
that's been a big big part and so now
we're seeing these PMI reports
suggesting that production could
deteriorate further as they deplete
these pipelines and aren't ordering new
stuff China on the other hand saw the
first overall Improvement in Factory
business conditions since prior to the
omicon Omicron Ray wave which was last
January this was the best reading for
China's PMI according to the survey
since May 2021. now that also aligned
with a report from the government folks
can be a little leery of government
reports but the government report showed
that manufacturing Rose at the fastest
Pace in more than a decade and that was
seeing export and also seeing export
orders expanding for the first time in
almost two years so the government's
report which some folks in business some
folks in the market can say hey yeah
China's government manipulates the data
so we don't trust that but this report
from s p Global kind of confirming those
reports showing nope there has been a
defined a clear pickup in Chinese
manufacturing activity manufacturing
still a big piece of that Chinese
economy the Eurozone like I said down to
48.5 from 48.8 but a little bit of a
silver lining here for Europe
manufacturing production volumes across
the Euro area broadly stabilized in
February ending an eight-month sequence
of Contracting output so basically eight
months output have been clearly going
down down down this month out uh the the
survey only showed a 0.3 percent decline
that's the best that we've seen in eight
months so a little bit of a silver
lining for the folks over there in
Europe one not so Silver Lining note
Germany had one of the worst reports of
all countries now that's important
because it's the largest economy in the
Eurozone and it and because Germany
relies very heavily on manufacturing so
a very manufacturing heavy economy is
showing a weak report and that could be
worrisome for the overall state of the
economy in the Eurozone but again could
be good news on the inflation front also
Japan shot the sharpest excuse me the
sharpest reductions in output and new
orders since July 2020. so things not
going great for the U.S the Eurozone
Japan the so-called Western World when
we talk about the West even though Japan
very much not in the west
um they're they're included as part of
that so the year the U.S the Eurozone in
Japan also in this very defined slow
down decreasing numbers Japan especially
leading the way down while China and
most of Asia saw increases a lot of
Emerging Markets uh showing that
decrease or showing that increase and a
positive response from the China
reopening this was certainly better than
expected for China and the rest of Asia
Russia also this was a big surprise saw
the strongest Improvement in
manufacturing conditions in six years
that's big a huge Improvement for Russia
in the midst of this war with Ukraine
now that could have implications for the
war because it could give Russia a bit
more cover to continue this war to keep
putting resources toward this war that
could impact the entire world because
you could see continued pressure put on
some of these commodity prices because
there still continues to be a trouble or
there's continues to be trouble or
difficulty getting some of those
resources that are exported by Ukraine
by Russia in the midst of this conflict
going on over there so definitely
something to watch our biggest takeaways
listen the first increase in global
manufacturing PMI since July 2022 we're
seeing that also this Chinese reopening
has had enough of an effect and again
China leading the way even with the U.S
the Eurozone and Japan in Decline the
reopening in China was strong enough to
kind of lift the overall survey to a 50
basically saying that things are
improving that was big the upturn in
production volumes in Asia was led with
Thailand India and the Philippines all
registering the fastest rates of growth
so those kind of big countries you think
about China and India huge one billion
plus population in China and India
Thailand and the Philippines not as
large numbers in terms of the population
size but big economic centers showing
that increase and being kind of the wave
that lifts all boats overall for the
global sector now this could also mean
renewed inflation Emerging Market
central banks some of those places like
Brazil like Russia Argentina were the
first to raise rates to combat inflation
because they've seen these kinds of
inflationary pressures before while the
U.S was a little late and some banks in
the euro in the Eurozone uh the bank of
England ECB were kind of late on the
trigger to that and they're still
raising rates well some of these
Emerging Market central banks have
already been raising rates for years and
they've raised them to some of the
highest levels in the world and now
they're seeing renewed inflation
pressures and some strong data from this
PMI report that could mean a renewed
inflation push across the globe and that
could mean that central banks have to
keep rates higher for longer we know
that's not good for the economy it kind
of chokes off growth and we could see
weaker results as a result of this so
definitely something to keep your eye on
sometimes good news can be bad news in
this case right now it looks like good
news is good news but don't sleep let's
check in with the market really quick I
want to check out like I said we're
going to start with these Commodities
because I think that's those are the
most sensitive usually to these in these
country reports especially stuff from
China
we're seeing oil right now Brent crude
and WTI about flat on the day now we've
seen a pretty strong decline in oil
prices over the past you know so far
year to date oil prices are down but
we're seeing right now A stabilization
and over the past few days we're seeing
a bit of a bounce back in oil we've seen
oil kind of pick up prices I want to
also point you to copper copper is
having a really big day up one and a
half percent right now on the day it's
copper is up right now let me see uh
copper up so far year to date about 8.1
percent now that's big gold has been
holding steady oil is down about 4.7 but
China's reopening has been said to be
pushing up the price of copper as they
say Dr copper it diagnoses the health of
the economy that's globally this
reopening from China folks have said ah
we don't see it we're not seeing it in
the data we're not seeing a lot of the
stock results well we are seeing it in
these PMI reports we are also seeing it
in those commodities prices with copper
up 8.1 percent and up one and a half
percent today you also across the board
when we go back when we look at this uh
we look at what really moves based on
some of these reports well the dollar is
down about half a percent today the
dollar Index the euro is up one percent
almost against the dollar now as the
dollar reduces in value a lot of those
things that are priced in dollars those
increase in value so this could be an
inflation story because it could push
the price of some of those Commodities
up higher as the dollar recedes we're
seeing the Europe way higher the Euro
way higher against the dollar day and
that's probably not based on this report
because as we've seen the Eurozone was
down the US dollar the U.S was down but
we are seeing the dollar weakening today
definitely something to keep your eye on
the stock market is up a little bit
overall reversing course at least the
Dow is the S P 500 is still down about
0.1 percent the NASDAQ down about 0.2
percent we have seen really a downturn
in stocks and markets really are looking
for that next Catalyst to move them a
survey like this is much more going to
tell us what's happening in the economy
than what's going to happen in the
market but we are seeing the stock
market kind of start to rebound uh the
Dow was down and pretty strongly
negative before this report came out we
are seeing a kind of rebound right now
as maybe this suggests that there are
some good signs in terms of inflation
slowing down maybe the FED not having to
do as much work from this report bond
prices of course we saw the uh the
10-year treasury yield hitting four
percent or a little earlier today it's
back down to about 3.97 and we're seeing
yields across the board the one year is
up at 5.1 percent the six month t-bill
5.15 some big numbers on those short
dated treasuries those moving higher uh
as well on the day so let's talk about
the the impact on the global recession
expectations this report says that
overall Global recession expectations
are probably decreasing China's fast
growth and the pickup the return to
growth after emerging from some of these
coveted lockdowns as we know China
reversed its covid lockdown policy for a
long time they had said if we discover
even one case we're shutting
neighborhoods shut in cities shutting
whole towns down they've said we're not
going to do that anymore we're going to
tolerate covid uh we're going to open up
some of the borders make travel more
available to people and we're seeing the
impact of that in this Global
manufacturing PMI report recently the
IMF World Bank and a number of other
Economic Institutions they have raised
Global growth expectations and said they
expect to see inflation peaking in the
near future uh we're seeing now the
other thing they did say and I want to
read you a quote here the balance of
risks remains tilted to the downside but
adverse risks have moderated since
October 2022 or since the October 2022
World economic Outlook so things seem to
be getting better for the overall
economy but the IMF San we're not out of
the woods just yet we'll say this report
does clearly show that China reopening
is happening it's not showing big
blowout huge numbers but the impact is
very clear and it's very clearly being
felt especially in Asia which is leading
the growth right now on the other side
recession worries in the U.S near Zone
remain very much alive especially in the
Eurozone this manufacturing data could
be big
again it's a much smaller part of the
overall U.S economy but a big part of
the European economy especially Germany
the biggest country and the biggest
economy in Europe and the economic
driver of the Eurozone uh in terms of
inflation there aren't big worries in
this report but we have seen of course
the U.S jobs data we have seen that CPI
data we've seen CPI data from a number
of companies a number of countries
showing inflation picking back up not
moderating as quickly as a lot of folks
have had hoped it would this is showing
that manufacturing is still growing and
that's not a concerning sign necessarily
but again central banks want to slow the
economy down they want to choke off the
economy and when manufacturing is still
Rising still increasing folks are still
going out there making big purchases
that's going to keep prices going up so
this did not do a lot to kind of dispel
the narrative that inflation is remains
a problem and it looks like it could be
remaining a problem globally and
worldwide recent surveys had a laid some
recession fears but also further fan
worries of further rate hikes but also
fan worries of further raid hikes
especially in the UK and U.S but also in
the Eurozone that's a quote from s p
Global from this report
um listen
here's what comes next uh I know you
watch Market takes because you're like
oh well that's great we analyzed the
data of what just happened but what
comes next we have no Market takes next
week I know y'all are sad please don't
cry
that said we have a double dip Market
takes the week after we are going to be
here breaking down CPI and retail sales
that's March 14th and 15th so no Market
takes next week we got the jolts report
job openings and labor turnover survey
but no jobs report next week that's not
coming out until or no job report this
week excuse me jobs report is coming out
next week but we will not be with you
we'll be with you the following week
doing CPI and retail sales uh be with us
for that consumer credit that report
comes out Tuesday be sure and take a
look at that we have seen consistent
increases in the debt that U.S consumers
have taken on
um and and that's something that I think
definitely everyone watching the economy
should be looking out for the consumer
credit report coming out Tuesday listen
that's going to do it for us here on
Market takes I'm your host Dion rabone
reporter for the Wall Street Journal I
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you were here with me and I
appreciate that we will see you on
Market takes next time